marché en famille le long du canal
lachine
un petit bonheur de la vie que pablo
savoure comme jamais il ne l'a fait
avant son mois de mars 2020 a été
cauchemardesque retour de voyage gros
symptômes grippaux et visait à l'urgence
de l'hôpital notre dame
il m'a dit écoute avant d'être tué il
faut compter donne de l'air parce que tu
n'arrives pas à respirer tout seul il a
53 ans un début de diabète et autour de
cholestérol élevé mais sans plus sa
situation se détériore
on le transfère aux soins intensifs de
l'hôpital général juif où il est
rapidement mis dans le coma pendant deux
semaines il vit alors ce qu'il a appelé
sa vie virtuelle et elle n'est pas
agréable
une des premières et hallucinations que
j'ai eus qui s'est répété c'était avoir
des serpents qui couraient autour de mon
lit et là je sentais qu'il y avait une
infirmière qui me touche et une c'est
mister hyde
c'est il faut c'est calme et si vous
bougez vous été intubé en ce moment vous
êtes grave et si vous bougez vous
remettez votre vie appel à son réveil le
médecin l'encouragent à lutter pour
rester en vie quand j'ai sorti du commun
c'est pas sûr de pouvoir respirer voir
moi-même et là c'était une discussion
avec moi même si je voulais continuer ou
non parce que c'est vraiment fatigué à
la maison marie claude sa conjointe ne
peut qu'attendre inquiète et infecté et
l'oci et les vides depuis
l'hospitalisation la paire des journées
c'est hors de mon année avec les
médecins le c'est devenu plus clair
qu'on était loin d'avoir gagné la partie
puis en même temps mon fils avait une
très mauvaise journée
parce que leur fils thomas attrape le
virus lui aussi maïté 18 en encaisse les
mauvaises nouvelles
c'était vraiment un peu ça en mode sur 8
ma famille plus que de penser à d'autres
choses mais c'était juste vraiment très
positive
le plus difficile a été de constater la
présence que je me suis réveillée dès
que je vivais encore dans un monde
j'étais désespéré parce que je me
rappelais plus des noms de mes enfants
je me rappelais j'essaie d'aider des
marchés je pouvais pas marcher
j'ai perdu vingt kilos pablo est
finalement retourné chez lui le jour où
cette photo a été prise trois semaines
après son départ vers l'hôpital mais il
était encore confus et est heureuse et
il recommence à sourire aujourd'hui la
coved 19 les aura changé pour le mieux
on a trouvé là dans des forces qu'on
avait peut-être pas anticipé puis ben on
appréhende soleil moi je veux donner un
message positif
la vie est tellement belle après tout ça
vraiment j'ai je suis attendait des
raies considérer puis des réapprendre à
vivre la vie d'une façon plus saine
là maintenant pour eux après des
semaines d'épreuves le ça va bien aller
de l'arc en ciel a pris enfin tout son
sens ici jean-sébastien cloutier radio
canada montréal